marine marine vous avez 18 ans vous
étiez en boîte jusqu'il ya 3 heures du
matin vous décidé de rentrer avec une
amie et vous n'étiez qu'à 15 minutes de
marche et ça de votre domicile vous
décidez de d'y aller à pied vous y allez
appeler vous rentrez chez vous à pied
ça se passe où déjà ça se passe à
nanterre d'accord atlas tu me dis qu'est
donc c'est en région parisienne vous
décidé de rentrer vous êtes avec une
amie qu'est ce qui se passe on marche
tous les dieux avec ma copine dans un
moment plein de joie on était très
contente ont été toutes les deux puis je
tourne la tête et je vois deux hommes
tout seul dans la rue non mais on est
toutes les deux avec ma copine je
préfère s'adresser savez que vous deux
se sent maintenant la lumière était
orange et on était bien que ça faisait
pas peur on était vraiment bien j'ai
tourné ma tête et j'ai vu ces deux
hommes j'en ai vu à engrais en noir je
les ai vus avec tous les deux un tour de
cou autour du cou mais il n'avait pas de
manteau et je me suis dit vu le temps un
tour de cou sans manteau ce pas normal
du coup le thé regarder je vois que plus
je marche fixe pluie marges 8 je vois
monter leur tour de cou sur leur nez
je dis à ma copine amelia un média je
pense que c'est maintenant il va falloir
concours là du coup je me suis mise à
courir j'ai traversé la route tue plus
vite que je pouvais malheureusement j'ai
trébuché et je suis tombé les deux sont
arrivés sur moi m'ont mis au sol celui
qui est avec son survêtement noir que
voulait à tout pris mon sac à main
c'était son but ultime
et c'est lui qui était en gris a
commencé amouroux et de coups de coups
de pieds dans tout mon corps sur ma
poitrine et surtout dans ma tête
et il n'arrêtait pas fait celui qui est
en noir lui disait arrête tu vas là
tuez-le saigne trop saigné trop tu es là
tu es c'est là qu'il faut arrêter
celui qui était en gris était dans une
folie il rigolait il prenait du plaisir
à me frapper il aimait vraiment sa fille
son coût du stress j'ai pas pu me
retenir est peut-être un peu la honte
mais je me suis fait dessus je n'ai pas
réussi à me contenir
et j'ai lâché mon sac celui qui est en
noir l'a pris les parties
et l'homme hongrie a sorti un marteau
qui a dans les bus et un marteau brise
vitre
et m'a regardé et m'a dit je vais te
finir je vais le finir
et puis il m'a roué à coups de marteau
dans la tête et puis à ce moment là je
me suis mis en pause et j'ai entendu mon
ami nathan jouer du piano j'avais une
douce mélodie au piano dans ma tête
j'entendais la tempe dire tu peux pas
t'endormir maintenant tu peux pas tu vas
t'en dormir tout à l'heure mais là il
faut pas que tu t'endors il faut que tu
restes là puis cette jolie mélodie de
piano s'est transformé en piano plus
batterie avec les coups de marteau et je
me faisais une musique qui me permet de
rester en vie je me remettais cette
musique dans la tête cette lumière qui
était si orange essai transformé dans le
sombre mes yeux était plein de sens je
me sentais mourir je me sentais mourir
je voyais gagner sa croûte in mes amis
dans ma tête je les voyais passer je
voyais ma famille
j'ai essayé de tenir du bien du mieux
que je pouvais et comment il a vu que je
commençais à perdre j'ai ouvert mes yeux
et ma bouche et j'ai fait la morte
et j'aurais jamais dû pour un juge
jamais pensé qu'un jour j'aurai faire la
morte pour m'en sortir donc pendant une
minute les couper ma respiration j'ai
fait comme s'il était morte après il est
parti
et je pense que personne ne peut
comprendre que j'ai pris une vidéo juste
après c'est un peu bizarre mais sur le
moment je me suis dit j'ai survécu à sa
et grâce à ces nappes château jour
d'aujourd'hui on peut avoir la
localisation de l'endroit et l'heure et
grâce à cette vidéo je me suis dit si
elle est dans mon téléphone si jamais
ils me tuent et que je cache mon
téléphone ma famille y verra que je me
suis fait agresser on pourra peut-être
retrouver mon corps au sera le lieu
regardez la vidéo que tu as posté juste
après son agression
[Musique]
alors c'est vrai que cette vidéo
c'est parle souvent des réseaux sociaux
médias vous avez raison sur ce coup là
réflexe ça a été un bon réflexe qu'est
ce qui a fait votre ami pendant ce temps
là en fait mon ami non il n'y ont rien
fait d'accord c'est me verse 50 mètres
derrière elle est restée a été tétanisée
par la peur elle essayait elle a crié
mais dès qu'elle criait il la regardait
qu'elle a arrêté de crier là s'il
appelait les pompiers la police bien
meilleure qu'à pouvait mais elle avait
peur de se faire tuer aussi sur le coup
donc elle a attendu et quand ils sont
partis j'ai attendu j'ai attendu un
petit peu je me suis dit c'est la force
de ses bras à me relever l'adrénaline a
fait que j'ai pu marcher
et puis là il s'est passé quelque chose
de dégueulasse c'est qu'il y avait une
voiture aux feux rouges je me suis hissé
jusqu'à celle voiture j'ai toqué à la
fenêtre s'il vous plaît monsieur aidez
moi je suis en train de mourir je me
suis à baisser la fenêtre et mathis
n'est pas mon souci
il a fermé la vitre et il est parti en
moulant
ma copine m'a dit c'est pas grave marine
c'est pas grave on va trouver de l'aide
c'est pas grave c'est des cons c'est pas
grave j'ai rencontré deux hommes qui
étaient dans une propriété qui m'ont
ouvert leurs bras et mis dans leur
propriété il a attendu que les pompiers
et les secours arrivent et sans ces
hommes là bas je serais peut-être pas là
et je le remercierais toute ma vie et si
moi je vous c'est un grand merci
vraiment un grand merci à vous parce que
malheureusement même s'ils n'ont pas
réussi à museler physiquement et
mentalement et au jour d'aujourd'hui je
suis juste une enveloppe corporelle et
florian
apporte de la tristesse à chaque fois
que je marche j'ai cette mélodie schiano
qui me rappelle que bien que cette
mélodie au piano qui m'a fait survivre
ça m'a fait énormément de mal
la douleur physique n'était qu'obsolète
par danton râlait de douleur que j'avais
dans ma tête je me suis senti sali
je me sens morte
je suis arrivé à l'hôpital avec les
urgences les pompiers les patrouilles de
police et les médecins m'ont dit c'est
quand même quelque chose dedans vous
êtes en vie et vous ne devriez pas être
en vie
mc asséné on m'a fait des traumas
crâniens il m'a fait énormément de mal
mais ouvert le crâne justice il ya avec
son marteau brise-vitre fins c'était
quelque chose de
très traumatisant et j'ai posté grâce à
mon amie agnès à ses vidéos sur
instagram parce que je voulais pas de
buzz même si j'aime pas du tout ça je
voulais juste que les gens voient que
même au jour d'aujourd'hui on n'est pas
protégé mais c'est pas pour autant qu'il
ne faut pas sorcier parce qu'on va pas
s'empêcher de vivre pour des gens comme
ça ça sert à rien
donc j'ai posté ça pour essayer de faire
passer un message et puis même s'il est
surtout de foot est égoïste mais essayer
de retrouver ces gens là bien sûr pour
qu'il paye ce qu'ils ont fait puisque je
trouve ça ignoble